in Iran this morning the Army vows to
quote confront the enemies and put down
a series of deadly protests mostly led
by women the protesters are Furious over
the recent death of a 22 year old woman
after she was taken into custody accused
of violating Iran's rigid dress code for
women there Remy inocencio reports on
the women who are challenging some of
the basic underpinnings Iran's Islamic
regime
taking off their head coverings and
waving them in the air
this is Defiance in Iran
and women are leading the charge some
are even burning their hijabs their
mandatory head coverings in protest
sparked by the death of 22 year old Masa
amini police allege she suffered a heart
attack after being arrested for wearing
an improper hijab they released this
security footage showing her collapse
CBS News cannot verify its authenticity
but critics believe she was beaten
saying her body was bruised and bleeding
it all started with a hijab how is that
possible there is a morality police
that polices the streets brings women in
punishes them Sanam vacil is an expert
in Iranian policy
the morality police are enforcers of
Iran's strict Islamic dress code well
documented confronting women sometimes
violently for not covering their heads
or bodies for conservatives and
hardliners within the system the hijab
can be a source of power or source of
identity for people that are against the
hijab it is the question of choice
really their lack of choice under Iran's
version of Islamic law but angry
Iranians are trying to break that
striking its symbols of government
Authority
and stoning an image of Iran's supreme
leader
some women are cutting their hair in
front of clapping crowds in solidarity
authorities are cracking down in some
cases with lethal Force
people are just fed up this is a
generation of Iranians that are pushing
back and the rising fear is that Tehran
will push back even harder
in the days to come
for CBS mornings raymie inocencio London